today we're putting the tech in
pyrotechnics as why it illuminates
what's inside fireworks now to start the
show we'll need a special black powder
known as well black powder invented in
9th century China this mixture of
potassium nitrate charcoal and sulfur is
basically what makes fireworks and other
explosives go boom
lighting the fuse of a firework ignites
the powder causing the potassium nitrate
to let off oxygen and that oh two leads
to losing ours by helping the other
ingredients burn rapidly producing hot
gases which launch the projectile into
the sky while a delayed fuse detonates
whatever primary payload the
manufacturers have packed into the fast
burning paper shelf for instance the
Rockets red glare as a bursts into the
air comes from strontium salts while
other metal salts create different
colors based on the amount of energy
produced when they burn or if you want
even more bang for your buck antimony
trisulfide a compound used in safety
matches creates a glittery effect and
you get colorful stars
if you bind metal salts and black powder
into pellets using dextrins
a starchy substance found in processed
meats and food glazes but for your own
safety please donate the fireworks
feeling wired yet subscribe